mr. Williamson you reported that you
came in last night
Monsieur my watch was stolen while I was
still one wild on you'll see we're not
yes you tell us take us through again
what happened
uh yeah basically I was just on my way
home from work last night and I was
waiting for the train and this guy came
up I think he had a weapon I think he
had a gun and he just he took life took
my watch I just I need to yeah
when you when you put a watch on like
that a flashy watch who are we really
wearing it for
look I hate to say it but you just need
to be more self aware that when you wear
a watch out like that you're really just
taunting people it's in our human nature
do you want to grab after wealth and so
a man strutting around with expensive
things it's taunting men just can't
dress nice when the sun goes down men
generally shouldn't wear a major brand
label after dusk really I have two sons
of my own at home and I would never let
them out of the house after 7 p.m. and
anything other than sweatpants yeah you
need to dress down mr. Williams were you
drinking the night that this happened no
I just got off work do you like to drink
couple have to work go on the weekend
did you try to disguise it you know is
there a chance that perhaps you gave the
man an idea that maybe you wanted him to
come look at the watch maybe you're
putting out a vibe that said hey look at
this watch
the manner in which you were walking
would you say that you were flashing the
watch I wouldn't say that maybe one
could even say that you were advertising
the watch can we just focus more on you
the guy that mugged me and four times I
don't watch listen man I wasn't doing
anything illegal I was walking down the
street the guy that mugged me that's
illegal my sons are in sweatpants every
day